[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  I don't regret staying at home and being  your mom but I regret not getting my  degree  that's why somebody's mom just enrolled  in college I'm referring to myself I'll  see you around the quad nobody says that  mom well bring it back I think those  guys just checked you out I'm just  looking at my smock it tends to catch  the light mom you're a college girl now  oh my god I make some changes no we  don't know where that's been Oh God over  here what are you 20  I love your mom I'm ready to get sex in  a public way we're in the stacks better  slacks no shut up Freight I'm older and  wiser this essentially a Google ask me  anything  turn off your Google you're scaring me I  think my google scared Jack last night  oh my god but in a good way I like when  you intentionally go through a haunted  house  [Music]